stunning in a well tell me about
choosing this come on you look so good
thank you
ah well it's comfortable it's stretchy I
feel like I'm in a yoga outfit to be
honest I hope it doesn't look like a
yoga outfit but it's very it's very
comfortable you can't to ask about your
figure how how do you stay in shape I
just have to fight eating a lot of my
favorite foods like french fries and any
carbohydrates which is a real drag and
you know why I have to just try to
dominate my diet with more proteins
that's my discipline keeping the carbs
down I play a lot of tennis I love
horses so I'm riding all the time I
think just staying active oh good for
you do you have cheat days though we all
have to oh I totally do yeah uh you know
my favorite junk food is our you know
dill pickle chips it's a Canadian thing
but I love dill pickle chips um yeah a
lot of sheep things but you know I try
to balance it out and reward myself when
I know I've done really well like after
tonight I'm gonna pick out on something
really bad I was gonna say tonight's a
reward night for sure how did you react
when you got the call that they wanted
to give you this award well I was just
surprised me I just didn't expect
something like this so early in my life
I have lived a lot so much already in my
life I've had such a long career already
but when I look at all the years left
and all there still is to achieve I
guess I just thought wow I don't know I
was overwhelmed like I think it was very
emotional
you